ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد ان
شاء الله تعالى
نبتدئ هذا
المساء بالنظر في ايات سوره الرعد من كتاب
الله وهي سوره
عظيمه و
جل معاني هذه
السوره حول معاني الشرك والتوحيد الذي جاء
به جاءت به
الرسل وجل معاني هذه الوره في اثر القران
وحول اثر القران على قلب ابن ادم
وهان هذا
الوحي من اعظم ما يمكن ان يكون لابن ادم
في
حياته ولا يحيا القلب الا بهذا
القران كما يقول سبحانه
وتعالى الا بذكر الله تطمئن
القلوب فهذه السوره في اثر القران على
القلب
وحقيقه
التوحيد الذي جاءت به
الرسل عليهم الصلا
والسلام ان شاء الله
تعالى سه
الران
قران through that we
cont in the prev years we
done
الانبياء سوره الحجرات
ان شا الله
تعالى سوره الر
سه
ران
قران
حجره
was and most of disc and discussion is
regarding the قران and
the that قران have on human being
heart also this chapter speaks about
the ty of تحد
‏what theis the prophets
is ان الله سبحانه
وتالى
توحي
الله ترتيب هذه
السوره 13 هذا ترتيب السوره من
ناحيه ترتيب المصحف الذي وقع عليه اجماع
الصحابه رضي الله عنهم في حياه او في زمن
ابي بكر الصديق رضي الله
عنه ترتيب
القران الصحيح انه
توقيفي توقيفي بمعنى ان الله سبحانه
وتعالى كما انه اوحى ايات
القران واوحى ترتيب ايات القران فكذلك
اوحى الى النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ترتيب
سور
القران هذا خلاف بين العلماء العلماء
رحمهم الله تعالى اجمعوا على ان ترتيب
الايات في القران في السوره الواحده امر
توقيفي يعني ان الله سبحانه وتعالى هو
الذي اختار
هذا الترتيب الذي نجده بين الايات في
السوره الواحده لكن الخلاف وقع بين
العلماء هل ترتيب
الور ايضا
توقيفي يعني هل هو من امر الله سبحانه
وتعالى من فعل النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
ام كان هذا الترتيب اجتهادا من الصحابه
رضي الله عنهم لان المصحف جمع
في بين
دفتين في زمن ابي بكر الصديق رضي الله عنه
كما روى الشيخان في
صحيحيهما فيما كان من استشهاد كثير من
الصحابه في معركه اليمامه ف اشار ابو بكر
او
اشار بعض الصحابه على ابي بكر رضي الله
عنه بان يجمع المصحف مكتوبا في كتاب واحد
حتى لا يخشى عليه من
الضيع ففعل رضي الله عنه وشرح الله سبحانه
وتعالى صدره
لذلك و وكل ابو بكر رضي الله عنه زيد بن
ثابت رضي الله عنه
بهذا الفعل بان يجمع القران فجمع
القران من الصحف والصدور يعني من الاوراق
ومن صدور الصحابه رضي الله عنهم بطريقه
معروفه وكان هذا المصحف عند ابي بكر رضي
الله عنه فلما توفي انتقل
الى عمر رضي الله عنه فلما توفي انتقل الى
ابنته حفصه ام
المؤمنين رضي الله عنها فبقي هذا المصحف
عند حفصه الى زمن عثمان الخليفه الراشد
عثمان بن عفان ذ النورين رضي الله تعالى
عنه
ف كلف زيد بن ثابت مره اخرى
ب جمع المصحف على قراءه
واحده
ففعل
و كتب عده
مصاحف قال بعض العلماء اربعه وقيل خمسه
وقيل سته وقيل ثمانيه وقيل تسعه خلاف بين
العلماء على كل حال جمعت قراءه المسلمين
على قراءه واحده وهي الرسم العثماني الذي
يسمى هذا الرسم
الذي بين ايدينا هو الرسم
العثماني فموضوع ترتيب الور هل هو اجتهاد
من الصحابه او هو امر من الله سبحانه
وتعالى
توقيفي والراجح الذي
يظهر ويتظاهر به الادله انه توقيفي انه من
الله سبحانه وتعالى كما انه اوحى ترتيب
الايات فكذلك اوحى ترتيب الور لان هذه
الور تجدها مرتبه بطريقه غير
ظاهره بطريقه غير
ظاهره سوره اله
الر
صحف
‏chap
قران
ران
قراند
رضي الله
عن
سه الفحه سوره
الناس
ران
قران الله سبحانه
وتالى
‏now
ران
قران الفاتحه البقره ال عمران
النساء المائده
الانعام صلى الله عليه وسلم
اللهج
deci
we veres of قران we the chapters
قران difficult hold any other
opap قران
صح from الله سبحانه
وتعالى صلى الله عليه
وسلم
ي
عنهم
صح think about
صح order would
necess mean all the chapter
s
‏it's in order
of revelation not order of date it's not
in order of timeline it has no timeline
it's in a
very
ud قران very very deeply looks into
different parts of the verses
‏reas chapters come after chapters and
chapters come before which that
bec
isation قران
because what is said the meaning so when
i when we have for instance سوره
الفاتحه سوره الفاتحه
البقره
قران اذا نظرنا في ترتيب
السور ذكرنا ان العلماء اجمعوا على ان
ترتيب المصحف ليس ترتيب انزال سور
القران ونقلنا ايضا اجماع علماء على ترتيب
ايات السوره الواحده ان هذا توقيفي من
الله سبحانه
وتعالى لكن ترتيب صور
المصحف هل هذا الترتيب توقيفي ام
اجتهاد
وصوب ان هذا
من التوقيف ان هذا من
الوحي ومن الاسباب على ذلك
اننا نجد ان المعاني التي
تفهم من ترتيب الور ايضا من معاني القران
معاني
القران من وحي
القران يعني ناتي على سوره الفاتحه
ثم يردف الله سبحانه وتعالى بسوره
البقره ايش المفهوم
بين لما ينتقل القارئ من سوره الفاتحه ثم
سوره
البقره معاني مفهومه هذه المعاني من معاني
القران ومن
الوحي كذلك اذا نظرنا الى ترتيب المصحف
نجد ان هذا
الترتيب ليس ترتيبا
ظاهرا يعني الترتيب الذي يتبادر الى الذهن
ليس هو ترتيب مصحف يعني مثلا ما ياتي هذا
الترتيب على حسب
الزمن
يعني
زمن
ال الوحي والا لكان الترتيب يختلف سوره
اقرا تكون اول
سوره وكذلك لا ياتي هذا الترتيب
بترتيب عهد يعني المكي المفروض ياتي قبل
المدني وليس الامر
كذلك ولا ياتي هذا
الترتيب على حسب الطول لانه المفروض
بالطول البقره تكون اول سوره وسوره
الفاتحه تكون من اواخر سور
القران ولا ياتي
الترتيب على
حسب
ما ت افتتح به الوره يعني مثلا الف لام م
كل صوره تفتتح بالف لام م هي
الوره التي تفتتح بالف لام
م المفروض تكون كلها مع بعض بعدين يجي الف
لام را وبعدين الف لكن الترتيب ليس هكذا
ايضا الترتيب ليس
على ترتيب
زمان
ذكر
القصص
سوره السور التي يذكر
فيها قصه ادم عليه السلام ثم قصه نوح عليه
السلام على ترتيب وقوع او حتى على
ترتيب وقوع الحوادث في زمن النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم مفروض تكون سوره
الانفال في معركه بدر تكون اول تاتي قبل
كثير من السور التي تاتي بعد لكن ليس هذا
هو
الترتيب بل الترتيب غير ظاهر وهذا يدل على
انه من
التوقيف
توقيف يعني انه
امر جاء من الله سبحانه
وتعالى
وجاءت هذه الترتيبات في العرضه الاخيره
العرضه
الاخيره العرضه
الاخيره هي المذكوره في حديث انس رضي الله
عنه ان النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم كان ياتيه جبريل في كل
عام
في شهر
رمضان فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ي
يتدارس القران مع
جبريل في اخر سنه جاء جبريل وقرا النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم وتدارس القران من اوله
الى اخره
مرتين هذه المدارسه وهذا العام هذه تسمى
العرضه الاخيره ليش مرتين لانه وقع ترتيب
وتاخير و تنظيم للقران
على النظام الاخير الذي سيكون عليه لان
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قد اتم الله
سبحانه وتعالى ايحاء القران اليه ولم يبقى
عليه الا ان يعرضه على جبريل حتى يثبت
ويثبته في اذهان
الصحابه
رر ‏it's the order that you would not
expect it's not an expected
order we don't see
that it's
from longest to shortest we don't see
that it is
from based on me me time and then med
time it's not based on what came first
there's no clear
order that you would expect
عن was
not was
اجتهاد رضي
عنهم مصح
oll
order
to
‏as would
narration the
companion
ising
ران don't any
things
do انس رضي الله
عنه
رمضان جبريل عليه
السلام صلى الله عليه وسلم
ضان
قران
us propet صلى الله عليه
وسلم and جبريل in order any
correction
made of in year of life year of صل الله
عليه وسلم life this happen
twice twice mean that قران
was صلى الله عليه وسلم جبيل
times this is referred to as the final
the final recitation the final
rehearsal that took place and that is
because that was going to be the last
ramadan that the prophet عل be on this
earth before his death and
‏order that isc
pr but is
not human would
expect
together
ال
حم سبح
يسبح together all the chapter speak a
certain thing toic together would that
easier would
beas
قران
قران اذا الراجح من اقوال العلماء ان
ترتيب سور القران وترتيب توقيفي وهو من
وحي الله واما اسامي
الور فاكثر اسامي الور هي
من شيء منها توقيفي وشيء منها اجتهاد يعني
بعض الصحابه
كان يسمي او يطلق على السوره والنبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم يطلق اسما على السوره على
حسب مطلع السوره يعني المف لام مم السجده
هي سوره السجده صصح ولا لا لانها تفتتح
بالف لام مم وفيها سجده هي السوره الوحيده
هكذا تكون كان امرها
كذلك
مثلا سوره
البقره هذه التسميه جاءت من النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم هي سوره البقره لانه مذكور
فيها بقره بني اسرائيل وهذه البقره ليست
مذكوره في سوى هذه
السوره كذلك الم لام
مم البقره هذه ايضا من اطلاقات الصحابه
رضي الله عنهم ف السوره التي فيها ذكر شيء
معين او مطلع السوره مع شيء معين يميز هذه
الصوره عن غيرها في ذهن السامع فهذه تصح
ان تكون تسميه وبعض ما سمى النبي صلى الله
عليه
وسلم بها بعض صور القران فهي توقيفيه وحي
من الله سبحانه وتعالى وبعضها اجتهاد من
منه وبعضها اجتهاد من الصحابه رضي الله
عنه وهذا الباب اوسع كثيرا من باب الترتيب
لكن اذا نظرنا في سنه النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم تجد
ان غالبا
99% اي حديث فيه كلام الرسول صلى الله
عليه وسلم فيه ذكر اكثر من سوره ياتي ذكر
هذه السوره على ترتيب
المصحف وكذلك قراءته صلى الله عليه
وسلم يعني مثلا في صلاه
الجمعه يقرا صلى الله عليه وسلم كان يقرا
كثيرا بايش بسوره سبح والغاشيه وهذا هو
ترتيب
المصحف كذلك النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول مثلا في حديث عبد الله بن عمر في في
السنن من من احب ان
ينظر
الى يوم القيامه كانه راي العين فليقرا
اذا الشمس كورت واذا السماء انفطرت واذا
السماء انشقت هذا هو ترتيب المصحف سوره
التكوير سوره الانفطار سوره
الانشقاق فهذه الادله كثيره ج جدا وهي تدل
على ماذا تدل على ان كما ان الله سبحانه
وتعالى اوحى الى نبيه صلى الله عليه وسلم
ترتيب ايه القران فكذلك اوحى اليه ترتيب
سور
القران صلى الله عليه
وسلم
‏we
find
have chapters قران we find come in ex
صح سبحان الله يعني
for سوره الاعلى ان سوره
الغاشيه صلاه
الجمعه instance when he would tell
others
toite a number of chapters he mention
more than one
us
صح
صل الله عليه
وسلم
رضي عنهم
مصحه
ال3
ص
صل الله عليه
وسلم
allain
قران
infu
ال
13 ويسبح الر
بحمده بح يعني بحمد الله سبحانه
وتعالى
والملائكه وهذه التسميه جاءت عن النبي صلى
الله عليه
وسلم صلى الله عليه
وسلم سنه هذه السوره سوره الرعد ذكرنا ان
بعض اسماء السور فهي توقيفيه جاءت عن
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم وبعض اسماء
السور هي اجتهاديه بعض الصحابه بعض
التابعين حتى
و
كذلك هذه السوره الرعد سوره
الرعد
يطلق عليها المف لام مم را الرعد وكذلك
يطلق عليها سوره الرعد اشاره الى الايه
الثالث عشر ويسبح الرعد بحمده وهذه
السوره اكثر اياتها في
ذكر معاني القران واثر هذا القران على قلب
المستمع على قلب الكاف على قلب المؤمن على
قلب التقي على
قلب غير التقي لان القران هو
كالماء كالغيث الذي ينزله الله سبحانه
وتعالى على
الارض
والقلوب
كالبذور
الناس
كل هذه الارض كل هذه القلوب تسقى بماء
واحد ويختلف اكل هذه
القلوب
هذا ينبعث منه الايمان ويكون له ميول الى
الجهاد وهذا له ميول الى القراءه وهذا له
ميول الى التقوى وهذا له ميول الى غير
التقوى وهذا يزيد المؤم هذه الايه
انزالها يزيد المؤمنين ايمانا وهذه الايه
انزالها يزيد الكافرين كفرانا وهلم جره
لان هذا القران وحي من الله فكما ان الله
سبحانه وتعالى ينزل ماء
واحدا ويختلف اكل
الارض ومن
الاراضي منها ما
يستفيد من هذا الماء ومنها ما يكون قعان
لا تنبت الكلا ولا تنبت الخضار ولا تمسك
الماء فكذلك وحي الله سبحانه وتعالى على
قلوب الانسان
فسالت اوديه بقدرها فاحتمل السيل زبد
الرابع كما يقول الله
وسناتر في اثر القران على
القلوب
وحقيقه الت والشرك
الذي بعث بها النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
والانبياء كفه الى الى
امم قران two things the first
is
exacte
ofis
that
‏sent what is it just bel that الله ex
الله the only
creat
epis
person n allah
created only created epit
الله
more differ between of believer of
disbeliever tye
nons right even
the those who worship idols even the
arabs in the time of the صلى الله عليه
وسلم مشركين باجماع
العلماء باجماع المسلمين
‏they a tye of they tye of monis in
their belief sy disc that's the first
topic of this chapter the second toic or
main subject matter of this
chapter is the eff
قران الله سبحانه
وتالى hearts of man it has a different
effect on the hearts of the good that it
do
الله سبحانه
وعالى and
earth types of things some parts of the
earth doesn't grow anything just holds
the water some parts of the earth grows
different things some parts of the earth
sucks in the water and
‏nothing grow and hold water
in noe
that الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه وتعالى
قران
‏of each
indiv it will bring for
that from each person
heart the water is the seed in ground
diff
and ان شاء الله نكتفي بهذا القدر ونكمل
غدا والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين لله رب
العالمين نعلن عن
وفاه وجنازه وعزاء الاخ يزن فره